we came messy ankle boots
playgrounds by the wide radius of no
resign where
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
and you
here
sick friends not related to your
love domain between jan great house of
truth says stone
all right
i
[Music]
today the citizen and my fears of
return bath
[Music]
types
the use of air already speaks sambar I te
I want this is normal I have
[Music]
and finally the institution
good
but this duty of teidagua for
years related grew up in mine does not have
break
[Music]
micron del leaf and bar living observe
wing is the tactical thing
[Music]
[Applause]
r has a hotel in the neighborhood kind of
earth that's one hundred months of timerman
initial meetings and remember the reverte
sanz continuous type
[Music]
tampico and complete
[Applause]
[Music]
that peace and have independence dni
it is very dignified very intimate to the button
[Music]
faymann in shirt
[Applause]
[Music]
two